[Music]
closer your hands are in your body and
the closer they are to your center line
do you understand but that means that
that's just an effort to overpower the
guys
okay
if you can kind of look at it as two
ways of understanding like kilo keep on
you can try you can try to make yourself
powerful
and then overcome this person
or you can try to make him not powerful
okay and that's more in alignment with
aikido and jiu jitsu not the first one
okay
so
uh
as he's coming around
and i bring this underneath me you see
um
the energy that you felt that was that
was allowing to push down on him and
make you feel powerful
again it's a yid young world well that's
where he can resist you see so he pushes
up and you're going to feel that
strength down there do you see
and people should
you should expect that he's not going to
go with the program
and he's going to push up once you're
out of kihon laws that you see
so as as he's pushing up that's what you
take forward you see it every little if
you slow it down
every time he pushes up instead of
pushing down on it he pushes up you're
taking it forward you see he pushes up
and you're taking it forward and that
way he's here you don't contest what
he's doing okay
so
that would be then that the pattern in
kihon is not here i know that looks like
it works but it's because he lays down
on you okay
but to keep this forward uh motion in
this
position
forward
it's going around
not
here
if you follow the rule that his center
must not stop
then it has to keep moving
[Music]
find the powders
the reason you do this one is as again
this one you feel strong because it's
easy to understand
put your weight on it
this one is going to require that
organizational integrity on
to hold your body
as the torque
is being stressed by his mass okay so
you're oh this is where you start
breaking it has to go together
and that's why it is conditioning you
not this but not this either okay
alright
his shoulder is still going down
do you see so you're still getting the
cross lateral check i'm not bringing
them up it's still going down
but it's going forward
here his
shoulder goes down but he's not going
forward
keeps going forward
[Music]
okay so so now the
just to understand what i'm talking
about your kid's gonna resist and not go
down you see that going down and then
you don't want to go
okay
so
as he's not going down that's the energy
now if you're late like i saw something
you're doing
you go here
and it goes in a wave
you see
that so just like
when he's pushing
like yesterday his his energy is going
through me so he can't lift my hand okay
so i'm coming around he goes i wasn't
pushing on it do you see and then i go
oh yeah push it forward
his energy is uh
passing through my hand okay
same exact way
passing through my
it doesn't flood okay
oh no
no no
just keep it moving keep it moving
keep it moving
but he's gonna
he's gonna
go go hard boom you got it he goes
that's the energy that i sent back okay
if he's not doing anything i can't do
that
got it when he goes high i don't push on
this
it bounces through
oh it keeps going around
you can't even tell that he's pushing up
on me do you get it okay